a rising number of educators deciding to
leave clark county school district 8
news now reporter kristen drummond
joining us live in the newsroom with the
issue and the concerns directly from
educators kristin well each board
meeting agenda
lists the teachers leaving documents
from the last three board meetings show
nearly 400 people deciding to
not continue with ccsd a significant
jump from the list posted in january and
february
now the reasons why vary but some
educators tell me
they're done just dissatisfied
dissatisfied
disgruntled and disappointed i have too
much experience and i have too much
education to be paid so low jeremy locke
says
low pay is one of the reasons he and his
wife plan to quit teaching in the clark
county school district next month
it's so political the duo came here one
year ago to continue building their
careers but
changed their mind about ccsd huge
problem of
valuing your people i see educators
making exit plans
national education association of
southern nevada president vicki kreidel
notices
this issue i personally know people who
just quit
and left because they don't feel
respected the clark county education
association sent me a statement
the teachers union president says the
numbers we're seeing so far
are slightly higher than last year
however they are lower than years prior
to last
it's hard to say for sure as we won't
know any final numbers until the end of
the school year
ccsd currently reports 479 current
teacher vacancies
that's around 2 percent of the roughly
18 thousand educators in positions
ccsd normally reports a teacher shortage
at the beginning of each school year
it remains unknown if it may double as
more educators decide to leave next
month
how's the morale for you and how was it
among your colleagues
the morale has been a struggle for
everyone this year ryan frommeltz does
not plan to leave his job despite his
concerns
while he stays the locks seek new
opportunities in education
outside nevada there's challenges to all
districts
the district created a commission last
year to focus on recruiting
and retaining educators reporting in the
newsroom kristen drummond
8 news now